if you're looking for a unique gift to
give this holiday season
we want to introduce you to alex ross a
line of hand-painted
wearable art check it out
[Music]
i've been drawing kitties because i love
kitties
um i have two cats myself and i started
drawing those
probably about 25 years ago
these characters have come alive to me
because in my imagination when i'm
drawing them i have a whole story
line and each one has a personality
my favorite of course is lucy because
she's my puppy
but i really like fergus and he's the
food critic our food critic
and i love brutus because he's grouchy
brutus is one of my favorite characters
because he was born on the wrong side of
the tracks
and every morning he gets up on the
wrong side of the bed
and he wanted to get a job so he went
down to the local five and dime
and got a job in the complaint
department
well soon everyone was complaining about
brutus because he had such a bad
attitude and he was such a grouse
grouch that he was sending customers
away so they had to close
down that department i just all her
characters have personality
and and the stories she wrote fit them
so perfectly
so it's just the whole thing is fun it's
my most fun
job i've ever had well i have we have 23
aprons right now so i've got 23 stories
and i've got more coming i called her
last
summer and uh when she did the mural on
my wall
and asked her if she would start drawing
uh specifically
as a business for us for aprons and and
purses
and so that's what she started doing and
we focused all her work on that
well we decided aprons because
we wanted it big we wanted the artwork
work
big and they show up great against the
white
and people are cooking more nowadays
because they're staying in their homes
and so we thought it would be a really
fun way for people to get into cooking
our aprons are really well priced and
they make great gifts and
anybody who sees them loves them so if
they're they're
perfect for christmas and the masks are
of course because everybody has to wear
a mask now
and it's more fun to wear something that
is
cute over your face than something
that's not cute
we have a website called alex ross dot
world
so go there and you can see all of our
aprons all of our adult and children's
masks we also have greeting cards
and uh wall art as well give alex ross
worlds a call
at 833-781-5222 or find them online at
alex ross.world right now they're
offering 20
off all products until december 24th and
each apron order comes with a free
matching adult mask
and character story card